problem 15 a restaurant is advertising
three item combination specials that
must include a main dish a vegetable and
a drink okay so you have to have at
least one of these so what are they
going to ask us how many three item
combinations include a soft drink and a
corn so three item combinations that
equal that include a soft drink and a
corn so let's reread what the conditions
a restaurant is not referring to three
item combination specials that must
include a main dish a vegetable and a
drink so you pick one from each of these
buckets so they're already picking two
of the buckets for so it includes a soft
drink has to include a soft drink and it
has to include a corn so they've
essentially already picked our choices
from this bucket and that bucket right
there and they're saying how many
combinations are left well we only have
two choices you know we only have salt
we only have freedom when it comes to
picking the main dish because the
problem has already picked for us our
vegetable and our drink the corn and the
soft drink and so there's only two
possible main dishes so those are the
three item combinations that include a
soft drink and a corn there's two
possible ones chicken and beef so it's
to is to make sure you understand that
what are the two combinations just to
make it explicit
well one combination is chicken corn and
soft drink right they're forcing the
corn and the soft drink on us and then
the other combination is beef corn and
soft drinks that's the second
combination because they're forcing the
corn and the soft drink on us so there's
two combinations but the way I just
thought about that is this thing has
been constrained for us the vegetable in
the drink so you could ignore it and so
how many combinations of main dishes are
there well there's two I just counted
them chicken and beef problem 16 Donald
priced six personal Compact Disc players
send they you know they wrote the CD
right there the prices are shown below
okay so these are six CD players what is
the median price so the trick of this
problem is just knowing what median
median literally means the middle price
so if I were to put all of these number
and orders in order which I'm going to
do right now the median is going to be
the middle number so let's put them in
order what's the smallest number here
there's 21 cross that out and then we
have another 21 so let me write that
down
I'll cross that out make sure I know I
used it the next largest number is 23 23
so let me cross that out
now the next largest number is 25 25
cross that out next largest number is 31
cross that out and then the next number
is 39 39 so what is the middle number
here well you see we have six numbers
and we actually there is no middle
number if we have an even number of
numbers there's no single middle number
there's two numbers that we can kind of
view as the middle these two numbers
here are the middle right I can't say 23
by itself is a middle because there's
two two above it and three below and I
can't say 25 is the middle because
there's two below it and three above it
so when you have an even number of I
guess data like you have right here you
pick the middle - if I had odd if I you
know if I had the numbers one two and
three but I could just pick I could just
pick the two but if I have one two three
and four I have to pick the middle two
numbers so in here I pick the middle two
numbers and I need a median and so what
I do is I average these middle two
numbers I take the mean or I go right in
between them so what's exactly in
between 23 and 25 well you could do that
in your head it's going to be 24 but if
you can't do it in your head you
literally would just add those two
numbers 23 plus 25 and then divide by 2
so this is going to be equal to 48
divided by 2 which is $24 and I just
explain that to you in just in case you
got you know the situation where these
some weird decimal numbers or these were
much larger numbers where you could just
say hey 24 is right in between those two
guys right there